mission nous décrypterons comme chaque
soir du lundi au jeudi
l'essentiel de l'information avec nos
invités et nos reporters sur le terrain
tout de suite voici les grands titres de
l'actualité de ce lundi 30 novembre
rétropédalage sur la tique 24 de la
proposition de loi sur la sécurité
la majorité a décidé sa réécriture
complète annonce cet après-midi du
patron du groupe la raim christophe
castaner la loi sur la sécurité globale
qui a été à l'origine de manifestations
parfois violentes partout en france ce
week end
gérald darmanin lui est auditionné en ce
moment même à la commission des lois de
l'assemblée nationale
reprise des négociations post break site
ce week-end entre londres et bruxelles
mais elles butent encore sur le sujet de
la pêche en dépit d'une concession de
l'union européenne boris johnson défend
bec et ongles à la souveraineté
britannique empêchant pour le moment
tout accord global avant la fin date
fatidique de sortie le 1er janvier
au nord du mali descamps forces
étrangères et maliennes visé
simultanément à ménaka à gao et kidal
des villes distantes de plusieurs
centaines de kilomètres
frappé par des tirs d'obus et de
roquettes aucune victime à déplorer lors
de ces attaques revendiquées par la
branche sahélienne d'al qaïda dont le
chef militaire a été tué le 10 novembre
par l'armée française
la majorité recule donc sur la partie la
plus controversée de la proposition de
loi sécurité globale le chef des députés
alarm christophe castaner a annoncé cet
après midi lors d'une conférence de
presse la réécriture complète de
l'article 24 une prise de parole après
une réunion avec emmanuel macron fin de
matinée l'ancien ministre de l'intérieur
dit vouloir clarifier cet article et
défendre la liberté de les presser coûté
en aucun cas nous ne voulons interdire à
qui que ce soit de filmer des forces de
l'ordre en intervention en aucun cas
nous ne voulons interdire la diffusion
de ces images sur les réseaux sociaux
en aucun cas nous ne voulons contraindre
les journalistes et citoyens à flouter
les visages des forces de l'ordre en
aucun cas nous ne voulons demander aux
journalistes de s'accréditer dans une
manifestation en aucun cas la volonté de
l'article 24 était d'atteindre à la
liberté de la presse ou la liberté
d'informer et gérald darmanin a donc été
auditionné la commission des lois de
l'assemblée nationale suite aux
dernières violences liées aux forces de
l'ordre
pour plus de précisions nous retrouvons
sur place notre reporter katia pique
nique
bonsoir katia l'audition donc débuté à
18h15 et elle est toujours en cours
oui absolument leur gérald darmanin
commencé par un long préambule au cours
duquel il a réaffirmé son soutien
indéfectible aux forces de l'ordre une
véritable déclaration de respect il veut
assurer la défense de ceux qui nous
protège at il assuré ils souhaitent
ainsi les aider un plutôt que de pointer
du doigt les dysfonctionnements il a
plutôt estimé qu'il fallait davantage de
formation d'encadrement notamment sur le
terrain il a évidemment critiqué le
problème des locaux vétustes du matériel
il faut davantage aider aussi au niveau
des conditions matérielles
il souhaite également que les sanctions
préconisées par l'igpn soit appliqué il
a fait un petit peu allusion à une
éventuelle réforme de l'igpn il est
revenu sur un outil selon lui précieux
la caméra piétons je vous propose
d'écouter gérald darmanin lors de cette
audition les caméras piétons seront
généralisés au 1er juillet à la demande
du président de la république pour
toutes les brigades de police et de
gendarmerie je m'en félicite
la proposition de la sécurité globale
permet d'ailleurs d'utiliser ces images
pour le chef qui regardera le sujet
notamment le pj qui est à l'intérieur du
commissariat de la brigade de
gendarmerie au retour de cette
intervention
et troisièmement les véhicules de police
comme de pompiers d'ailleurs pourrons
avoir dans le véhicule qui regardent la
voie publique ces caméras qui
permettront notamment d'avoir des
meilleures revues et de surveillance de
l'action de police les caméras elle
protège bien évidemment les citoyens d
accès tout à fait inacceptable de
violence de la part des forces de
l'ordre mais le protège aussi des
policiers qui vous le savez bien souvent
sont blessés vilipendé insulté
lorsqu'ils interviennent et
malheureusement aujourd'hui la voix les
policiers ne vont pas toujours la voix
de la personne qui est mis en accusation
et qui a pourtant commis l des actes
extrêmement forte contre les
représentants des forces de l'ordre
alors les réponses de gérald darmanin
était très attendue par les députés
notamment ceux de l'opposition
je vous propose d'écouter matile pas nos
députés insoumise olivier mas l'ex
député les républicains
c'était indispensable que le
gouvernement et la majorité
parlementaire réagissent après les
manifestations extrêmement forte qu il y
a eu ce week-end avec cinq cent mille
personnes dans tout le pays qu'ils m'ont
manifestée qui montrent qu'il ya une
opposition populaire à cette fois et
puis une opposition aussi
d'organisations internationales
notamment de l'onu mais aussi et de
toutes les organisations de défense des
droits humains dans notre pays ou encore
des syndicats de journalistes donc il
était peut-être temps de qu'ils
s'aperçoivent qu'il y ait un problème
malheureusement je pense que il continue
à s'entêter sur cette voie parce que je
ne vois pas comment ils vont réécrire
cet article d'autant plus que ça serait
presque drôle s'il n'y avait pas une
dérive autoritaire de voir monsieur
castaner notamment dire que finalement
cet article était très bien écrit et
qu'il offrait de nombreuses garanties
mais qu'il pouvait quand même y avoir
des interprétations qui nécessitait une
réécriture donc on attend de voir mais
nous on continue de demander le retrait
dans son entièreté de cette loi de
sécurité globale je suis un article sur
l'article 24 du gouvernement a fait
preuve d'une grande maladresse et il a
du mal à sortir aujourd'hui
'l'annonce d'ailleurs de la majorité ne
rime pas à grand chose puisque en
réalité le texte est voté donc il ya
plus rien à retirer c'est le sait le
sénat de droite qui va qui va devoir qui
va juger de ce qu'il faut faire de 2,7
de cet article 24 chacun en réalité au
delà de cette péripétie la manifestation
les manifestations importantes qui a eu
en france samedi dernier pour défendre
les libertés révèle un vrai malaise dans
notre pays sur la façon dont le pouvoir
emploi les forces de l'ordre les forces
de l'ordre ne sont pas au service d'un
pouvoir
elles sont au service du maintien de
l'ordre son service de maintien de la
paix et à son service de la loi et rien
d'autre alors sur la question de l'usure
des forces de l'ordre il a reconnu que
lors des manifestations des gilet jaune
de trop nombreux policiers qui ne
savaient pas faire du maintien de
l'ordre avaient pourtant étaient envoyés
faire du maintien de l'ordre je le cite
il n'y avait pas assez de crs et de
gardes mobiles
donc 300 vont être embauchés sinon sur
la question du tabassage dupont
producteur de musique il affirmé qu'il
souhaitait que les personnes suspendues
ou terme du processus judiciaire soit
révoqué ainsi tout était comme cela dans
la procédure et puis il a été évidemment
fait état du préfet l'allemand est bien
gérald darmanin a réaffirmé toute sa
confiance et david et qu'il ne
souhaitait pas parler dans son dos mais
qu'il avait fait un travail assidu et a
priori remarquable à son sujet alors
donc en revanche sur la question du
raciste et miki là qui a été détaillé
par la députée les lots bono il a
reconnu qu'il y avait un problème sur
lequel il voulait bien travaillé en
revanche sur de nombreuses occasions
autre question il a plutôt botté en
touche sur le lien de confiance avec la
population notamment ou encore la
question des black blocks
voilà ce qu'on peut retenir pour le
moment de cette audition de gérald
darmanin merci 4 sa technique en direct
non de l'assemblée nationale où cette
audition se poursuit toujours et à la
lumière des dernières violences qui ont
donc entaché l'action des forces de
l'ordre le premier flic de france est il
sur la sellette sa responsabilité et l
engager sa démission serait telle
nécessaire c'est l'objet de notre face à
face ce soir
[Musique]
et pour en débattre nous sommes en
direct avec sébastien meurant ans
sénateur les républicains du val d'oise
bonsoir sébastien meurant merci d'être
avec nous à vos côtés david guiraud
porte-parole jeunesse de la france
insoumise bonsoir vous également david
guiraud merci d'être là gérald darmanin
qui est donc auditionné ce soir ça
continue qui a tenté clairement de
montrer un soutien sans faille à la
police vous l'avez entendu j'imagine en
tout cas pour la première partie
sébastien meurant
il était important pour vous qu'il
s'explique le ministère le ministre de
l'intérieur ce soit il est important car
on assiste à des qit la déliquescence du
pouvoir il ya une crise de l'autorité et
qui n'a pas démarré lieu récemment
depuis le début et même macron nous a
inquiétés par cette dérive autoritaire
rappelez vous son surnom donné par ses
troupes s'étaient jupiter l'épisode
benalla a montré tout l'intérêt d'avoir
à filmer certaines interventions et donc
que le ministre de l'intérieur
s'explique c'est bien la moindre des
choses qui s'explique d'abord devant
l'assemblée nationale où ce vote les
lois et je note que la cette loi est cet
article qui pose problème puisque ce
parti pourra revenir au sénat c'est le
cet article a été voté par la majorité
présidentielle
il est quand même surprenant de vouloir
écrire cet article que m'avait demandé à
priori à la demande du président de la
république mon par un comité théodule et
qui a ému même le président de
l'assemblée nationale monsieur c'est
grand et y compris la président de la
commission des lois de l'assemblée
nationale
alors david guiraud on entend sébastien
moreau sénateurs les républicains je
précise qu'ils voilà qui est souligne ce
côté très adroite des ministres de
l'intérieur vous je ne vous demande pas
si
gérald darmanin vous a convaincu devant
les députés
- est-ce que non me le demandez pas la
simple mais mais ce qui en fait moi ce
que j'observe c'est qu'ils sont en train
de changer de discours
et pourquoi ils sont en train de changer
de discours pas parce que monsieur
darmanin n'est plus quelqu'un de droite
et parce qu'il ya une mobilisation
citoyenne
c'est à dire que des gens sont descendus
à plusieurs centaines de milliers dans
la rue pour dire que les libertés ce
n'était pas quelque chose d'accessoires
et que l'on ne pouvait pas accepter ce
discours qui est toujours le même depuis
des années de dire il faut que vous
sacrifiez d'une partie de vos libertés
soit disant pour garantir votre sécurité
est ce que fait le gouvernement avec la
loi de sécurité globale ce qu'il fait
notamment avec l'article 24 mai pas que
c'est qu'en fait ils empêchent aux
citoyens de se protéger d'autres choses
parce que vous savez dans la sécurité et
la sûreté il ya d'autres choses que
juste se protéger de ces autres
concitoyens potentiellement dangereux
mais aussi des abus du pouvoir et des
abus des représentants du pouvoir est en
fait la multiplication des images ne
fait que confirmer que oui il ya des
abus depuis des années et que c'est pas
juste une question de brebis galeuses
dans la police mais deux responsables
police politique de responsables publics
qui n'ont pas voulu organiser des choses
de manière à ce que ça se passe bien et
donc forcément quand vous avez des
discours un peu guerrier comme ceux
darmana au début qui nous disait tout
assumé il ya un temps soutenu 12 ans
quand même fut un temps où on nous
disait qu' il n'y avait pas de violences
policières qu'il n'y avait aucun racisme
que tout allait bien et c est bien
maintenant la réalité se confronte à
monsieur darmanin il change de discours
donc effectivement il a un peu sur la
sellette
pourquoi parce que moi j'estime quand
même que quand vous changez de disque
vous changer de politique
c'est difficile d'incarner de ligne
politique à la fois oui alors justement
je me demandais si le son on l'avait
justement ce sont de gérald darmanin qui
évoque ces violences policières et qui
n'est pas tout à fait d'accord justement
avec l'opinion publique sur ce thème on
va écouter le ministre de l'intérieur
qui s'exprimait c'était cet été j'ai
justement lors d'une audition devant la
commission des lois de l'assemblée
nationale
quand j'entends le mot violences
policières moi personnellement je
m'étouffe la police exerce une violence
certes mais une violence légitime c'est
vieux comme max weber
sébastien meurant c'est ça le problème
c'est ce climat là photo climat au
discours guerrier instaurée par le
ministre de l'intérieur est encore
quelques mois selon vous non dans le
problème ce ne sont pas les violences
policières il ya des actes qui sont
répréhensibles au sein de la police mais
la violence
elle n'est pas policière la violence et
la lan monte en france il n'y a pas de
sentiment d'insécurité il ya une
véritable violence qui est vécu par nos
concitoyens
et moi qui suis sénateur du val-d'oise
je peux vous dire qu'il ya dix années ma
grand mère ne servait pas sa porte
lorsqu'elle était chez elle et que
maintenant
icd impossible il ya une vraie violence
qui monte dans la société il ya tout un
tas de phénomènes et les policiers sont
les premières victimes des violences
parce que il y a des centaines de
policiers agressés chaque jour et le
respect des forces de l'ordre n'est plus
ce qu'il a été
donc monsieur madame anna où le problème
c'est que il assume un discours qui est
le sien un discours que lui demande
d'assumer le président de la république
puisque il faut plaire à la fois et à la
droite et la gauche
le problème ce sont les actions et ce
sont les résultats d'une politique
on a mis avec le pays à feu et à sang
avec des postures très martial est dans
une période de confinement il est quand
même complètement impensable d'avoir des
centaines de milliers de personnes qui
manifestent et la donne on parle pas des
mesures barrières donc le problème et
c'est un problème qui est fondamental
c'est que ce pouvoir est en
déliquescence
il ya une crise de l'autorité et qui est
alimenté par un pouvoir qui est
impuissant à résoudre les vrais
problèmes de sécurité des français
car entre la la sécurité mise à
l'intérieur et le garde des sceaux il y
a un vrai problème nous a pas échappé
quand même qu'il y avait il ya peu de
temps
des policiers qui ont été malmenés dans
mon département à herblay qui sont qui
était entre la vie et la mort il ya eu
des il ya peu très peu de temps des
attentats terroristes et qu'on a un vrai
problème de sécurité en france et il est
violent ce n'est pas le problème de
violence policière c'est le problème
effectivement de dérapage de certaines
personnes mais je posais sur et là je
soutiens les gens heureux je soutiens
que la police dans son immense majorité
est remarquable et avait républicaine
donc il ya comme dans toute corporation
des acquis sont rentrés en cible là ces
personnes ces policiers il faut être
sanctionné mais dans leur immense
majorité
ce qui est scandaleux c'est qu'on peut
voir des black bloc tapez massacrer des
policiers on peut voir des policiers qui
attendent des jugements d un policier à
céret et donnant quatre ans vous rendez
compte ça fait quatre ans qu'il attend
un jugement
donc là il ya un problème de cohérence
de ce pouvoir qui à la fois sécuritaire
et de justice est une réelle montre une
david guiraud sur ce problème de crise
d'autorité en france il n'ya plus de
sécurité votre réaction
non mais on nous dit que que il
s'agirait de certains policiers personne
ne dit que tous les policiers sont des
racistes salle aux violences et passe à
la question la question c'est quand vous
regardez par exemple les images de
michel est clair vous avez quatre
policiers qui sont des agresseurs sont
nés puis des gardiens appelés ce sont
des agresseurs n'y a pas d'autre mot bon
mais le problème là dedans c'est qu'ils
sont pas que quatre il y en a 15 autour
d'eux pendant les deuxième scène celles
qui ont été données par l'outsider qui
sont passifs face à des choses compte
qu'il ne devrait pas accepter par
exemple michel déclare se prend des
coups au visage alors qu'il ne se défend
pas par terre il ya aucun des collègues
de ces gens violents qu'il peut qu'il ne
pense à les arrêter de la même manière
que vous avez de plus en plus ce genre
d'événement ou en fait sur par exemple
ce piège faut bien il ya des mensonges
donc on ne sait pas évaluer les choses
et surtout les gens violents dans la
police aujourd'hui sont ce qui entraîne
des policiers qui sont sûrement intègre
au jour le jour je dis pas le contraire
mais ces gens violents intel entraînent
dans leur logique des policiers qui eux
ne gagnerait à être détachés débarrasser
de ce genre de policiers aux violences
et à dire qu'en fait les pouvoirs
publics ont organisé une situation où
les mauvais éléments de la police ont
une influence considérable dans les
actions parfois dans les paroles sur des
policiers qui eux moi je veux bien le
reconnaître qu'ils font bien leur boulot
parfois mais qui se retrouvent dans ces
logiques là et logiques parfois de un
peu de silence parfois d'omerta et
souvent quand vous regardez les récentes
affaires les policiers mentent
voilà c'est quelque chose qu'il faut
reconnaître alors ils demandent pas tous
mais sur sophia show via sur sur cédric
souviens par exemple les policiers ont
menti ce sont les vidéos qui ont permis
à la fille de renvoyer c'est aussi çà
s'est
histoire humaine la fille d'un père qui
est mort de savoir pourquoi et comment
son père était mort et le faux et usage
de faux est une pratique malheureusement
aujourd'hui dans la police qui s'est
trop généralisée parce qu'on n'a pas
voulu contrôler ça on a considéré que
parce que les policiers été assermenté
ça se passerait mieux et vous savez moi
ça ne me plaît pas cette situation
j'aimerais bien qu'on n'ait pas besoin
de filmer les policiers mais aujourd'hui
pour de beaucoup de citoyens
c'est la seule arme qu'ils ont face à
des policiers assermentés et c'est ça le
problème de la loi sécurité globale
c'est que aujourd'hui malheureusement
c'est leur seul instrument de défense a
beaucoup de citoyens face à des
policiers qui effectivement parfois en
viennent à mentir et c'est ça le
problème c'est que effectivement vous
avez un journal un policier qui fait une
journée de travail où il va sauver des
gens où il va aider par exemple des
fameux qui se font battre par leur
conjoint je ne le nie pas mais il suffit
qu'une fois dans la journée il ya une
injustice sur cassure un citoyen pour
que le rapport de ce citoyen là par
exemple sur un contrôle au faciès qui
dérape pour que le rapport à la police
de ce citoyen là soit durablement
impacté est de plus en plus
et effectivement pendant les
manifestations des gilet jaune on a vu
ce sentiment quelque part pas à se
généraliser ya encore beaucoup de gens
qui ont confiance à la police mais quand
même
le gouffre s'accroît ses organes a
redonné mois la généralisation à partir
du 1er juillet des caméras piétons
annoncé un par gérald darmanin lors de
son audition ça peut être un début de
solution
dans le contexte actuel c'est ça amène
un peu d'accalmie
mais il l'a dit lui le problème ce ne
s'est pas assez s'est pas laissée par
les caméras le problème c'est que le
métier de policier le métier de crs
métier défendeur est de plus en plus
difficile et c'est pas de la faute des
forces de l'ordre
la société est de plus en plus violente
il ya des causes et ses cecos il faut
traiter parce que vous allez boire est
venue de fournir les policiers nationaux
les policiers municipaux qui a tort on
va devoir fournir aussi les caméras au
vigile dans les magasins qui sont pillés
par des casseurs
ces agressions répétées fonds qui lie à
un climat et une réelle insécurité qui
monte
année après année en france et cette
insécurité se répand auparavant c'était
limité dont certaines banlieues on
appelait chaude et aujourd'hui c'est
partout en france où il y à un
affaiblissement énorme de la sécu à de
l'eau de la sécurité un affaiblissement
de l'autorité
et l'autorité des policiers qui étaient
inhérents au port d'un uniforme au
respect que l'on devait aller à la loi
aux règles aux usages et aux moeurs
c'était 7,7 respect de l'autorité et de
moins en moins partagez donc les caméras
sont un début de solution mais le
problème est tout autre
le problème c'est de faire en sorte que
les policiers ne soient pas adressé que
les policiers soient dans un climat de
sérénité et la mettez vous à la place
des policiers
il ya bien plus de policiers de blessés
que dérapages et de bavure et là je
voudrais insister
ça fait les gros titres tous les médias
en parlent là où on a complètement
oublié les policiers qui ont été
victimes d'agressions les policiers
assassinés les policiers ont ça ça fait
pas les gros titres
donc il ya ya ya ya un vrai problème de
climat en france qui est un climat
certains disent de climat de pseudo
guerre civile lorsque lorsqu'on a des
manifestants qui se permettent devant
l'oeil des caméras de briser des des
commerces de saccager l'arc de triomphe
on n'a jamais vécu ça même pendant les
heures les plus sombres de notre
histoire
l'arc du triomphe des symboles de la
nation de la république n'ont pas été
saccagés et là mais quand on aime on
parle il ya quelques centaines de
plaques de l'inconscient podium le
pouvoir nana na na intervient pas là il
vrai scandale avait été à la source de
ces villes dire le mot de la fin c'est
déjà la fin pour revenir à la question
initiale de notre débat ce que ça
changerait quelque chose finalement le
départ du ministre de l'intérieur qui a
d'ailleurs je le rappelle renouvelé sa
confiance au préfet de police parisiens
eux l'allemand moi je pense que ça par
exemple le départ du préfet l'allemand
changerait concrètement des choses parce
que je pense que c'est un homme
dangereux pour monsieur darmanin moi ce
qui m'intéresse c'est surtout de changer
sa politique non j'ai appelé plusieurs
fois à la démission de nombreux membres
du gouvernement donc je peux le refaire
mais je pense qu'aujourd'hui ce qui est
important c'est de garantir les libertés
publiques et de retirer la loi sécurité
globale quant au climat de violence
qu'on énonce attendait ça n'est pas vrai
qu'on n'a jamais connu cette situation
pendant les filets jaunes sur le saccage
de leur doctrine on peut rappeler vous
les i
je de mai 68 sont infiniment plus
violente ces des voitures retournées sur
toute une avenue sur tout un boulevard
saint germain etc
et pourtant il n'y a pas eu autant de
m'arracher il n'y a pas eu de ie éborgné
donc en fait il faut regarder les choses
avec lucidité
aujourd'hui il ya un gouffre qui se
créent et la question si on veut arrêter
de voir à la fois des citoyens se faire
frapper et en même temps aussi
et parce que c'est important je le
reconnais arrêtez de voir cesser ces
situations aussi de violence envers les
fonctionnaires de police il faut qu'on
s'organise refondre totalement par
exemple le fonctionnement de la police
nationale requête thione le rôle de
l'igpn est évidemment il ya aussi des
choses à faire et urgemment par exemple
vu les images notamment de mediapart et
c'est quelque chose que personnellement
je dis depuis longtemps
il faut dissoudre les bacs qui sont
devenus un instit une institution très
honnêtement qui sont dangereuses pour de
nombreux citoyens et dont je ne vois pas
très bien l'utilité aujourd'hui
concrètement pour les gens sur le
terrain
merci à vous deux en tout cas ça sera
peut-être l'objet d'un autre débat cv ça
me rend et david guiraud a versé d'avoir
été avec nous en direct sur rt france et
c'est dans ce contexte que le candidat à
la présidentielle de 2000 22 jean luc
mélenchon indique souhaiter le retour du
service militaire obligatoire il indiqué
dans un entretien accordé à l'opinion
l'idée avait d'ailleurs déjà émergé lors
de sa campagne en 2017
mais le leader de la france insoumise
propose également d'élargir les missions
des conscrits jusqu'au sein de la police
car je cite cela changerait le regard de
la population sont st pauli
s'échangeraient les pratiques internes
de celle ci le racisme et la violence
ils reculeraient fin de citation et pour
en parler nous sommes avec alexis
poulain éditorialistes bonsoir à l'itie
poulain merci d'être avec nous rétablir
le service militaire obligatoire ça
pourrait être utile dans ce contexte
selon vous alors il s'agit pas seulement
du service militaire c'est un service
civique
l'idée c'est d'avoir
des jeunes qui seraient utiles à la
communauté à la fois au sein de la
police des pompiers mais aussi des
associations pour de lutte contre le
changement climatique et autres
donc c'est beaucoup plus parce que
simplement la conscription de l'époque
et le service militaire et c'est un peu
l'idée du sc nice si vous voulez qui a
été porté par la majorité actuelle mais
avec
un dédommagement à hauteur du smic donc
c'est assez différent puisque là les
jeunes seraient payés pour travailler à
des fins utiles pour la société alors
surtout selon la proposition de jean luc
mélenchon coni conscrits 1 effectue des
missions au sein même de la police
il dit ça pourrait changer le regard de
la population c'est un début de piste
alors c'est une idée effectivement de
dire que si les enfants des uns et des
autres sont au sein de la police on aura
un regard différent un regard de
l'intérieur
il est temps effectivement de cesser de
faire de la police 7 ce camp adverse
pour certains avec ses appels au meurtre
de policiers acab all cops are bastards
etc
donc oui si les familles comprennent ce
qu'est la police voient leurs jeunes qui
sont pendant un an neuf mois au sein de
la police pour des missions de service
civique
ça serait sans doute le regard que les
français auraient de leur police
puisqu'il se l'approprient rey à nouveau
il comprendrait que cette police elle
fait corps avec la république et qu'elle
n'est pas là contre les citoyens mais
bien au service des citoyens et c'est et
c'est ce qu'elle est d'ailleurs la
police c'est juste que les images des
dernières années font qu'on commence à
douter que la façon dont est traitée
sont traités les manifestations aussi
font peur aux manifestants et donc il
est temps de changer ce regard il est
temps aussi de 2
de rabibocher les populations et
notamment les français avec leur police
et changer les pratiques de celle ci les
pratiques internes notamment comme le
dit le leader de la france insoumise oui
la question bien entendu de la doctrine
de l'encadrement de la formation
d'ailleurs il n'est pas le seul à le
dire gérald darmanin en parlait devant
une commission devant l'assemblée donc
il ya un problème de formation de
formation continue des forces de l'ordre
de la façon dont aujourd'hui les les
les gendarmes les policiers ceux qui
sont là pour protéger finalement ne sont
pas formés complètement ils sont formés
à des gestes techniques ils sont formés
bien sûr au niveau du droit mais il ya
tout un travail qui va au delà sur
l'encadrement sur l'humain sur la
désescalade qui a été fait d'ailleurs
part des voisins européens mais pas
forcément qui a été le choix de la
france et il est temps de se poser la
question de la doctrine et de
l'organisation interne de la police
et donc ce service national
au sein des forces de police permettrait
peut-être de voir aussi d'avoir regarde
extérieur et de faire évoluer le travail
des forces de l'ordre au sein des
quartiers et au sein des populations
merci alexis poulain pour votre
éclairage merci à vous restez avec nous
dans quelques instants à nous parlerons
des négociations post break site entre
londres et bruxelles elle patine
toujours en cause le secteur de la pêche
et puis direction le mali des camps de
forces étrangères mayenne ont été visés
soultan aimant à ménaka gao et kidal
dans le nord du pays aucune victime
n'est à déplorer rester avec nous
[Musique]
mais
tu as une famille qui a recruté dans
toutes les couches de la société sans
faire de tri des mineurs des femmes des
délinquants des criminels de droit
commun tout le monde est venu à jaca en
syrie il ya encore quelques quelques
années au moment de charlie hebdo
clou du bataclan il y avait un état
islamiste qui semblait diriger tout ça
la bascule et se fait justement en 2015
et smith est un peu le passage de relais
d'al qaïda l'état islamique quelques pas
dans notre politique internationale vis
bien évident qu'il faut pas créer les
conditions à nouveau une terre de jihad
et de cet appel d'air justement au
recrutement l'a malheureusement fait en
syrie en irak
[Musique]
la chasse est un lobby donc il pèse très
lourd il faut arrêter de dire que on a
besoin des chasseurs qu'on a besoin de
régulation on n'a jamais eu la preuve de
ça cette réduction du débat justement
entre le tout blanc a le tout noir ne
nuit-elle pas finalement à l'idée même
que les français pour espère de la
chasse je crois pas que ce soit réduire
le débat de rappeler que c'est un
plaisir qui va jusqu'à la mort cc c'est
ça l'essentiel et c'est pour ça que
c'est un sujet très très épidermique
parce que c'est une histoire de vie et
de mort il faut protéger la végétation
faut protéger la faune il faut protéger
notre santé
tout ça c'est y est n'oublions pas tous
nos problèmes viennent du mépris qu'on a
sur le reste du monde vivant donc il
faut il faut arrêter de laisser les
chasseurs faire leur bêtise et je suis
poli
[Musique]
est ce que la ville dense et mortifère
ce n'est pas la danse ip brut
c'est-à-dire le rapport entre la
population un territoire qui est porteur
garde de causalité d'explications mais
des densités un grain si l'on dit
d'appartement il ya des chaînes de
contagion du fond avaient d'ailleurs
vraisemblablement du milieu familial
parce qu on a des familles qui vivent à
trois générations et c'est tout cet
ensemble de causes qui
constitutionnellement un syndrome en
quelque sorte social et dont le colis
est à la fois le révélateur est
malheureusement la cause déterminante
ponctuelles
je suis très frappé entre présentant des
sciences sociales par finalement le
progrès considérables comme à fait dans
cette endémie qu'avant dérivation n'a
pas que des mauvais côtés en un an on a
mis au point pratiquement avec
[Musique]
20h30 heure française merci de nous
rejoindre en direct sur rt france c'est
une nouvelle semaine cruciale pour le
break si les tractations entre
négociateurs européens et britanniques
ont repris ces dernières heures pour
londres les pourparlers entre désormais
dans leur dernière ligne droite et
précision des lames medjahed l'union
européenne et le royaume uni s faire
arracher un accord post break site dans
les prochains jours les négociateurs
européens michel barnier et britannique
david frost ont repris les discussions
ce week end
il tente de dissiper l'épais brouillard
qui entoure l'avenir de la relation
entre long d'un bruxelles et le temps
presse la période de transition
permettant de conclure un accord de
libre-échange approche à grands pas sans
traité commercial d'ici le 1er janvier
prochain les échanges entre les
vingt-sept et le royaume uni se ferait
selon les règles de l'organisation
mondiale du commerce
synonyme donc de quotas et de droits de
douane les deux camps court le risque
d'un nouveau choc économique
au centre de ce bras de fer entre
londres et bruxelles qui dure maintenant
depuis 9 mois
l'accès des pêcheurs européens aux zones
britannique
il ne peut y avoir d'accord s'il n'y a
pas un accord satisfaisant qui donne un
accès durable et large aux eaux
britanniques l'absence d'accord ou un
mauvais accord sur la pêche aurait un
rebond sur toutes les politiques de
pêche en europe
remettant en cause un équilibre
patiemment conçu nous avons quelques
jours encore beaucoup de chemin à
parcourir
et si le royaume uni croit que la
question du temps joue en sa faveur
ça n'est pas le cas le négociateur
européen serait en revanche prêt à faire
quelques concessions
selon des sources européennes michel
barnier aurait notamment proposé que lui
restitue 15 à 18% du total des quotas
européens pêcher dans les eaux
britanniques
une proposition qui ne semble pas
convaincre londres pour le ministre
britannique des affaires étrangères
dominique rab la pêche reste je cite une
pomme de discorde majeure
dans les discussions post briques site
l'incertitude plane donc plus que jamais
le déblocage finale se fait toujours
attendre
les négociateurs vont en tout cas devoir
conclure un accord suffisamment tôt pour
permettre sa ratification par le royaume
uni mais aussi par le parlement européen
qui tiendra sa prochaine séance plénière
à la mi décembre
ce maison expert en relations
internationales bonsoir claude henchoz
maison mère fille d'être avec nous entre
bruxelles et londres qu'elle est
finalement selon vous la vraie date
limite des négociations ben écoutez en
tout cas l approche parce que à force de
reporter la date limite effectivement
l'année dernière pour négocier le traité
sur la sortie politique de la
grande-bretagne de l'union européenne ce
a finalement marché lors d'un conseil
européen et on s'est finalement mis
d'accord sur un traité qui a été signé
et ratifié cette fois ci c'est un petit
peu différent parce que la méthode de
négociation des uns comme des autres
c'est à dire des britanniques comme de
l'union européenne
c'est de dire je suis tout à fait
d'accord pour conclure un traité mais à
condition que ce soit suivant mes
propres termes c'est à dire suivant mes
conditions et évidemment cela ne marche
pas alors il est probable que les
négociateurs vont continuer leurs
travaux
toute cette semaine et que et bien comme
l'année dernière c'est finalement le
conseil européen qui est l'instance
suprême de l'union européenne
la réunion des chefs d'état de
gouvernement qui se réunissent le 10 et
le 11 décembre en principe sur d'autres
sujets mais qui devront probablement
évoquer ce sujet et voir s'il est
possible d'arriver à un accord donc la
date limite pour trouver un accord
c'est le 11 décembre si ensuite les
parlements nationaux n'ont pas le temps
de ratifier le traité
c'est pas très grave puisque on a
l'habitude dans la région internationale
de mettre des traités en vigueur par
anticipation à titre provisoire alors
boris johnson
at il un calendrier politique en faveur
ou bien en défaveur d'un accord il a les
deux il a dans sa poche gauche a un
calendrier politique avec une absence
d'accord
et effectivement c'est tout à fait
conforme aux personnages puisque il a
sculpté sa stature politique autour de
l'idée qu'il était le seul premier
ministre capable de sortir le
royaume-uni grande bretagne de l'union
européenne et de ne plus se soumettre à
aucune règle émises par bruxelles
que ce soit des règles de concurrence où
que ce soit les règles de la cour de
justice de l'union européenne
donc il pourrait tout à fait se
satisfaire d'un odile et il l'a dit à
plusieurs reprises
même s'il dit qu'il veut négocier
jusqu'au dernier carat parce que bien
entendu il ne veut pas être jugé comme
responsable de l'absence d'un accord aux
yeux du monde entier
donc il est peu probable que ce sera un
négociateur très difficile maintenant à
linverse si par miracle il y avait un
accord le 11 décembre si madame merkel
parvenait à assouplir la position de
boris johnson est peut-être celle aussi
des partenaires européens et bien dans
ce cas-là boris johnson dire est
formidable c'est le premier accord de
libre échange
si le deuxième accord de libre échange
puisque j'en ai déjà avec le japon et je
vais enseigner une cinquantaine avec les
pays du monde entier
donc ils crieraient victoire à n'en pas
douter et il aurait évidemment le
soutien des milieux d'affaires
britanniques qui sont très préoccupés
par cette affaire et surtout la city et
les milieux et des milieux financiers
claude blanchemaison l'europe
serait-elle vraiment la grande perdante
faute d'accord moi que la grande
bretagne
c'est un jeu dans lequel tout le monde
risque de perdre dans un une absence
d'accord mais la grande bretagne
beaucoup plus que l'union européenne ne
serait ce que parce que 50% ses
exportations sont dirigés vers l'union
européenne et que s'il n'y a pas
d'accord et bien les deux parties
imposeront des droits de douane par
conséquent il y aura une entrave
libre circulation des marchandises et
puis du côté de l'union européenne on
n'aime pas beaucoup les confrontations
on préfère les compromis et les accords
donc là je pense que l'union européenne
préfèrerait avoir un accord mais
naturellement elle n'est pas prête à
souscrire un accord aux conditions de
monsieur boris johnson aux conditions de
la grande bretagne et notamment en ce
qui concerne la pêche comme ça a été dit
dans votre sujet c'est sans doute le
point le plus difficile puisque la
grande bretagne veut retrouver
recouvrait la souveraineté intégral sur
ses os sur ses eaux territoriales sur
les eaux dans lesquelles les pêcheurs
français belges et quelques autres de
pêche traditionnellement depuis déjà
très longtemps même avant le traité
d'adhésion de la grande bretagne et que
ceci naturellement est inacceptable pour
la partie européenne et notamment pour
les pays dont je viens de parler s'il
n'y a pas d'accord d'ailleurs
et bien nos pêcheurs ne pourront plus le
1er janvier aller pêcher dans les eaux
britanniques
c'est aussi à considérer quand on écoute
monsieur bonne il a tout à fait raison
monsieur bonne
l'absence d'accord perturbera
complètement à la politique de la pêche
dans toute l'union cassera les écrire
mais ce qui est vrai aussi c'est que à
partir du 1er janvier les pêcheurs
français n'auront plus accès aux eaux de
la grande bretagne et qu'il faudra sans
doute compenser ce dommage par des aides
budgétaires qui pourront être nationale
ou européenne
alors je crois que dans ce jeu chacun
essaie de faire peur à l'autre en effet
en essayant de garder son jeu final son
ultime et les concessions ultime pour le
lien des moments et le dernièrement
celle 11 sél et 11 décembre
merci à vous claude blanchemaison expert
en relations internationales d'avoir été
avec nous et sur la question de la lutte
contre l'immigration la france et le
royaume-uni s'accordent dès demain paris
et londres avant boom
et leurs patrons idronais radars pour
détecter les migrants qui tentent de
traverser la manche et la mède rendre
impossible la traversée clandestine de
la manche entre le nord de la france et
l'angleterre
c'est en clair ce que prévoit cet accord
entre paris et londres pour y arriver
les patrouilles françaises vont être
doublées dès ce mardi de nouveaux moyens
technologiques seront aussi déployés le
long des plages françaises des drones et
des radars vont être utilisés pour mieux
surveiller la manche
par ailleurs il y aura bientôt un
nouveau système d'asile qui sera fermé
juste et une nouvelle législation sera
mis en place l'année prochaine
le royaume uni s'est engagé à faire un
investissement financier supplémentaire
de 31,4 millions d'euros pour soutenir
les efforts importants de la france
contre les traversée irrégulière
un nouvel accord entre le royaume uni la
france qui fait suite à des traités
bilatéraux déjà signé en 2004 et 2018
des textes qui prévoit le financement
par londres d'une partie de la lutte
contre cette immigration clandestine en
échange du renforcement de la présence
policière près des ports du nord de la
france
un dossier migratoire un dossier
migratoire qui a été régulièrement
source de tensions entre paris et
londres
le royaume uni a souvent accusé la
france de ne pas s'impliquer
suffisamment pour empêcher les
traversées des traversées de la manche
qui ne cessent de se multiplier avec
leur lot de drames il y à un mois encore
quatre personnes dont deux enfants ils
sont mortes noyées dans le naufrage de
leur embarcation de fortune à l'aide de
canots pneumatiques de kayak voire de
gilet de sauvetage
pas moins de 6000 200 migrants à tenter
entre le 1er janvier et le 31 août de
rejoindre les côtes britanniques depuis
le nord de la france
attaques simultanées aujourd'hui dans
trois villes du nord du mali
des explosions ont eu lieu à kidal gao
et ménaka des villa distante pourtant de
plusieurs centaines de kilomètres des
tirs d'obus et de roquettes ont visé
avec en militaire abritant des forces
internationales selon des habitants et
un responsable des nations unies
aucune victime n'a été rapportée après
ce qui semble être une rare opération
coordonnée contre les forces étrangères
un habitant de kidal a déclaré avoir
entendu plus de dix explosions en
provenance du camp pour les soldats de
la paix et les soldats de l'onu pour
l'opération française barkan al qaïda a
revendiqué la responsabilité de ces
attaques
et pour en parler nous sommes à décaler
tounkara sociologue directeur du centre
des études sécuritaires et stratégiques
au sel
bonsoir alliés car à merci d'être avec
nous des attaques simultanées à kidal
ménaka et gao clairement que chercher à
faire les terroristes alors écrit le pré
les coups violents au nord et aux sens
du mahdi il estime le quotidien des
populations des 1012 certes de
différentes réponses apportées la france
elle a porté également par l'armée
régulière du mali ainsi que c'est
l'oeuvre la face au midem amini cement
permis d'assister à un débit telles
qu'elles sont quand même qu'il suffit si
les groupes locaux violents notamment à
l'horizon du tenant du mali ainsi que la
frontière avec l'état islamique continue
à se vider façon tout à fait remarquable
rappelons quand même que 2019 a
aujourd'hui le mali à travers ses
différentes phases de défense de
sécurité à pogny victimes dans les
monnaies également à une bonne partie
également
et même la force onusienne à ces
éléments ont été touchées également par
ses attaques répétées à la fois
aunisiennes des maliens
pourquoi ces attaques aujourd'hui quel
est ce timing je pense que plus potez
elle est plausible
parmi ces il faut quand même évoqué
l'attitude plus ou moins rigoureuse la
france où sont les jeunes offre de
dialogue avec cette vous plaidez pour
lesquels dialogue avait été calé mais
les hits et par un nombre important des
moyens lors des assises qui ont humilié
un des 1017 même sens des mélodies dans
les mêmes temps on peut aussi comprendre
à 1 depuis des attaques considérant que
vous pourrez trop violents notamment n'a
pas de la part de la sasp à cannes
française c'est quand même une réponse
aussi assez différent de la tête vous
pouvez au dif en sa présence que les
forces britanniques au mieux la région
seulement musique mais d'aller même
temps et continue à inquiéter à la fois
et les populations civiles mma militaire
donc je pense que c'est un message fort
qui venait placer pas ce groupe a du
coup violent à l'encontre de dix ans
emmanuelle mais qu'on veut repenser
justement l'opération barkan avec
davantage d'européens à ses côtés c'est
selon vous une bonne option stratégique
concrètement aujourd'hui lorsqu'on
analyse de façon objective les dix ans
les dépenses militaires sont proposés
par le quai d'orsay
sans ces dépenses qui sont quand même tu
as fait sa mue et mais ils ne suffisent
pas pour des raisons tout à fait
évidente beaucoup de maliens et
l'édition opération militaire n'était
pas aussi le dc10 en attaque terroriste
les quelques opérations militaires
notamment étrangère souffrent également
démis réelle coordination avec les
fonctions consenties par les éléments de
la force
sommes-nous en face des actions
militaires malheureusement qui ne
tiennent pas suffisamment compte de
toute la dimension humaine en voilà un
temps plongé du conseil joue
si de l'état aujourd'hui quand même la
france elle a porté par les dépenses
militaires même l'humanitaire mais
lesquelles ils pensent malheureusement
et peine à voir un ancrage local par
personne c'est que ce n'est pas qu'ils
souffrent d'insuffisance de coordination
et même de collaboration avec les
obstacles sans violence effectivement la
l'instabilité semble extrêmement
difficile à gommer pourquoi est ce si
compliqué c'est quasiment une mission
impossible selon vous il est important
de la paix dit que lorsque les tourismes
simple at il faut le long terme serait
que très souvent on succombe
sensationnel la si vous voulez on
raccourcit même dangereux qu'une partie
du monde sont parvenus à éradiquer mais
pour lui ce soit dans un laps de temps
je crois que j'ai longtemps il est
vraiment nécessaire même s'il est
difficilement compréhensible par les
communautés notamment celles qui vivent
à aucun de ses différentes formes de
violence mais je pense que
fondamentalement hausse de 10,7
persistante les sécurité interrogent à
la fois la nature du danger qui sont
apportées dès 2013 à horizon 10 mais
dans le même temps ça ce nouveau système
l'épineuse question de collaboration
avec 1171 notamment la face au mcs en
français la force onusienne d'amusement
et la force défense dix équipes les
alpes et du mali se sont comme des actes
est certes qui s'est battu contre le
limit et dénis qui est l'étoile isma
mais malheureusement les quelques
combats mous monde à suffisance que
souffle de coordination souffre ou même
à la collaboration de façon effective en
séduction d'amener merci à lee
sociologue directeur du centre des
études sécuritaires et stratégiques au
sel merci d'avoir été avec nous avoir
apporté votre analyse et cette attaque
meurtrière qui a frappé ce week-end le
nigeria après deux sont des civils dont
de nombreux agriculteurs ont été
assassinés dans le nord-est du pays par
des membres présumés de boko haram
c'est de loin la tacc le plus important
de perpétrer contre des civils depuis le
début de cette année les attaques
commises le jour des élections locales
l'épreuve
r depuis l'insurrection djihadiste et au
combat l'émotion est palpable nigeria
après l'attaqué djihadistes qui a
durement frappé l'état du borno dans le
nord-est du pays
samedi une centaine de civils en majeure
partie agriculteurs ont perdu la vie
alors qu'ils travaillaient dans des
champs le 28 novembre en début d'après
midi
des hommes armés sont arrivés à moto et
ont mené une attaque brutale sur des
hommes et des femmes qui travaillaient
dans des champs à cochons b une attaque
qui n'a pas encore été revendiqué et qui
pourrait bien avoir été menés par le
groupe djihadiste boko haram ou bien par
le groupe etat islamique en afrique de
l'ouest dans cette région en proie à une
insurrection djihadistes depuis plus de
dix ans les agriculteurs pêcheurs et
bûcherons de la région sont
régulièrement la cible des islamistes
ils sont accusés de transmettre des
informations à l'armée nigériane ou de
ne pas payer l'impôt réclamé par les
groupes terroristes
un drame condamnée par le président du
nigeria et je condamne le meurtre de ces
agriculteurs dévoués à leur travail par
des terroristes
le pays entier est blessée par ces
assassinats un sens et une attaque
symbolique alors que l'état du borno
voter pour des élections locales pour la
première fois depuis 2008
un scrutin sans cesse repoussé pour des
raisons de sécurité depuis 2009 et
l'émergence de boko haram
on dénombre dans la région plus de 36000
tués et le déplacement de plus de 2
millions de personnes en ethiopie le
premier ministre éthiopien habib ahmed
déclare que la principale ville de la
région du tigré mekele est sous le
contrôle des forces fédérales
de son côté le leader du front de
libération du peuple du tigré appelé le
gouvernement à retirer ses troupes de la
région et mettre un terme à cette folie
assurant que le conflit se poursuit sur
tous les fronts un conflit suivi par le
chef de la diplomatie américaine
mais pompéo a d'ailleurs demandé
aujourd'hui au premier ministre
éthiopien une cessation totale des
combats habillés ahmed
sûr que la situation est sous contrôle
et écouter le premier ministre éthiopien
nebe là ils pensaient que les drones
étaient destinés aux bombardements
mais nous les utilisons pour surveiller
leur mouvement nous les surveillons jour
et nuit
madame mais qu'elle est est à nous elle
a été construite avec nos ressources
nous n'allons pas la détruire
pas même une seule personne n'a été
blessé par l'opération à mékhé les
savants en 1 à présent les agriculteurs
continuent de manifester contre de
récentes réformes libéralisant les
marchés agricoles
des dizaines de milliers se sont rendus
à new delhi la capitale ce week end la
condition paysanne une question
politique majeure en inde dont deux
personnes sur trois vivant en zone
rurale
françois fisc et beach ils convergent
papier ou en tracteur
depuis jeudi des centaines de milliers
de paysans du pendjab en colère tentent
de prendre d'assaut la capitale et
compte bien y rester
chacun de nos tracteurs est chargé avec
des provisions pour quatre mois
le blé a été semé et des agriculteurs du
pendjab et de l'haryana sont maintenant
tous libres tant que le gouvernement
n'aura pas annulé ces nouvelles lois
aucun d'entre nous n'y retournerons
on est venu ici pour faire en sorte que
le gouvernement retire ses lois notre
mouvement de protestation se déroule
depuis deux mois dans l'haryana et le
pendjab mais le gouvernement n'y prête
pas attention on a décidé de venir à
delhi pour faire pression sur le
gouvernement national afin qu'il retire
ses lois des lois adoptées fin septembre
par le gouvernement du premier ministre
narindra maudit pour les agriculteurs
fini de vendre leurs produits uniquement
sur les marchés régulés par l'état avec
des prix fixés ils ont dorénavant la
liberté de les vendre à un acheteur au
prix de leur choix mais le parti du
congrès le principal parti d'opposition
au pouvoir au pendjab à cusset réforme
de mettre les paysans à la merci des
gros acheteurs privés sans aucun pouvoir
de négociation on est des agriculteurs
comme la plupart des gens au pendjab
on pense que ça aurait un effet sur les
marchés agricoles publics et qu'on
devrait s'adresser aux marchés agricoles
privés qui nous paierait des tarifs
arbitraire pour nos produits
donc le prix minimum garanti par le
gouvernement ce qu'on obtient pour nos
produits agricoles ça va s'arrêter
des protestations qui ne touche pas que
le monde agricole
jeudi à l'appel de onze syndicats contre
la révision des lois sur le travail et
la libéralisation de l'agriculture
plus de 250 millions d'indiens ont
arrêté de travailler le temps d'une
journée soit la plus grande grève de
l'histoire
l'épidémie coronavirus au mexique à
présent confrontée à une recrudescence
de cas le pays qui compte plus d'un
million de contamination vient de
dépasser la barre des 100000 morts pour
désengorger les hôpitaux le gouvernement
ouvre davantage de centres de dépistage
c'est le cas dans les rues de mexico
mais se faire tester reste là bas aussi
très compliqué etienne pierre maille
admise mazari certains patientent depuis
l'aube dans la tente d'un test face à
l'explosion du nombre de contaminations
la ville de mexico a déployé plus de 200
tentes de dépistage dans les quartiers
les plus touchés par l'épidémie
des test rapide et gratuit mais face à
un afflux massif de la population
les files s'allongent et les autorités
peinent à atteindre l'objectif de 20
mille tests quotidiens
pourquoi cela prend si longtemps il y a
beaucoup de demandes et malheureusement
ça réagit lentement
c'est notre troisième tentative de
passer le test
selon une récente estimation de
l'université d'oxford
le mexique est l'un des pays qui
effectuent le moins de tests au monde
priorité aux personnes âgées et à celles
et ceux qui présentent les symptômes les
plus sévères
mais à mesure que le nombre de cas
augmente les entreprises demandent de
plus en plus à leurs employés de se
faire dépister
[Musique]
nous délivrons un certificat officiel
scellé par mexico
beaucoup viennent ici pour cette raison
parce qu'on leur a demandé au travail de
passer le test
il y a aussi beaucoup de gens qui
présentent des symptômes et nous
détestons face aux pics
d'hospitalisation dans la capitale le
gouvernement mise sur une campagne de
dépistage massive pour tenter d'endiguer
l'épidémie le mexique lui vient tout
juste d'enregistrer son record quotidien
de contamination avec plus de 12000 cas
quant au nombre de décès enregistrés
dans le pays
il s'établit à + 205000 reste avec nous
dans quelques instants nous reviendrons
sur la course au vaccin et la stratégie
de la france la haute autorité de santé
recommande de vacciner en premier les
résidents des ehpad et les
professionnels de santé au contact
direct des malades
et puis nous parlerons du budget de la
sécurité sociale pour mai par la crise
du coc vide
l'assemblée nationale a approuvé en
lecture définitive le texte par 60 voix
contre 39
[Musique]
comment choisissez-vous un film un
projet un scénario un réalisateur avant
de choisir on ait choisi ce qui fait le
propre d'un acteur c'est de partager des
sentiments des idées des émotions
vous vous êtes vraiment dans le cinéma
de créateurs d'initiateur je crois que
le cinéma c'est comme la peinture c'est
comme le la littérature ça reste un art
tête comme maintenant c'est l'industrie
qui gagne mais du coup peut-être qu
est-ce qui va rester c'est que les films
qui seront de plus en plus fait pour le
cinéma et pas sur les grands réseaux
resteront des objets artistiques godard
qui disait cette chose si forte
quand on regarde la télévision en baisse
les yeux quand on va au cinéma enlève
les yeux de teddy
[Musique]
on vit tous les jours sans faire
attention que tout en dépend c'est
l'unité de mesure de toute chose une
convention admise par tous s'il arrive
quelque chose tout s'arrête
[Applaudissements]
vous conviendrez que c'est l'argent qui
fait tourner le monde
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
peu importe que ce soit des bitcoins du
bon vieux cash
nous vous parlerons de tout sans langue
de bois
[Musique]
la france oubliée c'est une rencontre
avec ces citoyens qui ne se résignent
pas à la fatalité
on est comme tout le monde je suis
répond en appartement on est énervé dans
le sentiment qu'il faut à chaque fois se
battre ils vivent parfois au bord des
routes nationales pas forcément loin de
paris mais toujours loin de ceux qui les
dirigent
moi je vois des remarques ont ils
fassent un tour de tracteur etc
bookmakers campagne il faut savoir c'est
qu'une vie différente
ils ont le sentiment d'être des français
de seconde zone comme s'ils étaient
invisibles bas pourrait t'aider un peu
plus aujourd'hui la france oubliée c'est
montrer ce qu'on ne voit jamais
[Musique]
nora lakehal a été la première femme à
intégrer le groupe
islamisme radical de la saur c'est
l'élite des renseignements généraux de
la police française
c'était après les attentats du 11
septembre et quand on vient vous voir et
qu'on vous dit ben écoutez vous avez de
la première femme qui allait rentrer
dans ce service
vous ne pouvez absolument pas refusé
votre mission première est celle de
traquer ces terroristes ce prêcheur
salafistes il vous a des tranchées pour
reprendre un code policiers il vous a
reconnu que voilà c'est fini pour moi
est ce que ça remet en armes
tout est passé dans ma tête est ce que
vous avez appris de ces profils
qu'est-ce qu'ils vont chercher
d'ailleurs dans la religion le profil
vient toujours de la misère sociale
quand on écoute comme ça du majeur mais
quel est le rapport avec la réducation
mais c'est la radicalisation
il faut que nous reprenions la place
dans le cerveau des enfants et de la
jeunesse
[Musique]
certains disent que nous ne sommes pas
une chaîne française
d'autres affirment même que nous ne
sommes pas journalistes mais vous
[Musique]
savez-vous vraiment qui nous sommes
les valeurs que nous défendons la
liberté
la liberté d'expression et d'opinion
nous défendons l'égalité l'égalité des
chances pour tous
[Musique]
nous sommes une équipe
nous sommes c'est diversité qui fait la
france
et nous en sommes fiers
[Musique]
et si vous veniez voir par vous même
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
et
21h heure française merci de nous
rejoindre en direct sur rt france pour
cette deuxième heure d'émission tout de
suite voici les titres de l'actualité de
ce lundi 30 novembre
la stratégie vaccinale en france c'est
ce qui se peut à peu la haute autorité
de santé recommande de vacciner en
premier les résidents des ehpad et les
professionnels de santé au contact
direct des malades
la campagne sera lancée au plus tard
début 2000 21 selon le gouvernement la
société est moderne à elle déposé
aujourd'hui des demandes d'autorisation
de son vaccin aux états unis et en
europe
un défi vertigineux celui du budget 2021
da sécurité sociale après six semaines
de navettes entre le sénat et
l'assemblée les députés ont donc
approuvé le texte en lecture définitive
par 67 voix contre 39 qu'ovide oblige
les dépenses explosent pour les hôpitaux
les tests des salaires des soignants est
désormais la vaccination qui se profile
[Musique]
en israël le ministre de la défense venu
danse vient de geler sa commission d'
enquête sur l'achat de sous-marins
allemands après une demande de la
justice une affaire dans laquelle sont
visés des proches de premier ministre
avait émis netanyahu de liban entame
aujourd'hui un déconfinement partiel
après deux semaines de fermeture quasi
totale du pays après une réunion hier du
comité ministériel chargé de la gestion
de la pandémie le ministre sortant des
santé a annoncé la réouverture
progressive de l'ensemble des secteurs
et commerces et l'annulation du système
de circulation alternée
[Musique]
il débite buts avec les derniers
chiffres du coronavirus en france santé
publique france dénombre quatre mille
cinq cas de kovy détecté en 24 heures
quatre cent huit personnes sont décédées
à l'hôpital ces dernières 24 heures le
taux de positivité des tests s'établit
désormais à 10 9% et poursuit sa baisse
alors à quoi va ressembler la campagne
de vaccination en france la haute
autorité de santé vient de donner ses
recommandations en la matière pour une
campagne qui devrait débuter dès la fin
de l'année compte tenu du nombre limité
des doses l'organisme recommande de
vacciner en premier les résidents des
ehpad et préconise cinq femmes
progressive avec une ligne directrice
protéger en priorité les plus
vulnérables et ceux qui s'en occupent
[Musique]
avoir confiance dans le vexin proposé
c'est donc tout l'enjeu du gouvernement
qui doit présenter cette semaine sa
stratégie alors votre faut-il
privilégier le vaccin classique ou
moderne quelle logistique adopter pour
le distribuer l'échelle du pays pour
quel résultat place à notre décryptage
avec nos invités et pour en parler nous
sommes avec l jean paul stahl
infectiologues au chu de grenoble alpes
bonsoir jean paul stahl ya d'être avec
nous à vos côtés de thierry lardeux noah
médecin généraliste président de la
caisse autonome de retraite des médecins
de france bonsoir à vous aussi thierry
lardinoit est la haute autorité de santé
qui a donc présenté un ses
recommandations cinq phases progressif
de vaccination ça vous paraît adaptée de
procéder par ordre ce qui j'ose dire de
fragilité série l'art de noix écoutez si
vous permettez un petit trait à la bhl
sur le sujet je voudrais déjà vous dire
que personnellement je n'ai aucun
conflit d'intérêts de quelque nature que
ce soit et que je suis à titre personnel
extrêmement favorable aux vaccins que je
considère comme étant des choses très
intéressantes et qui ont troqué fait
progresser la médecine dans un bond
phénoménal dans ce dernier siècle en
revanche le un traitement quel qu'il
soit en médecine doit être basée sur sur
de la sueur de la confiance et c'est là
où il nous faut nous nous recentrer donc
je ne sais pas si la priorisation qui a
été faible des vaccins et la priorité
c'est la question que je me pose un
petit peu parce qu'il faut essayer de
revenir un petit peu à de la science
qu'est ce qu'un vaccin
un vaccin c'est l'utilisation de tout ou
partie d'un agresseur microbien de rendu
inoffensif pour l'inaugurer en être
humain de façon à ce que ce dernier
développe des défenses immunitaires
donc ça c'est connu depuis très
longtemps ces pasteurs qui a dénoncé le
lancer l'idée était développé ça a été
développée depuis
qu'est ce qu'un vaccin à evans message
et c'est quelque chose d'un petit peu
plus compliqué et on s'aperçoit
actuellement qu'il y à une sorte de
glissement sémantique sur le terme
vaccin parce qu'en fait effectivement
sachs 1 alan message et c'est plutôt un
élément de thérapie génique dans la
mesure où on va utiliser un arn
messagers étrangers qu'on va introduire
dans le corps humain lequel fabriquer
d'antigène et c'est contre cet antigène
que ensuite le corps fabriquera des
anticorps donc dans le sens strict du
terme on peut pas réellement conseiller
de considérer que c'est vraiment un
vaccin en tout cas c'est ce et c'est un
glissement sémantique c'est une
c'est une ère nouvelle c'est une ère
nouvelle dans la médecine c'est une
autre façon de penser la médecine et de
penser la protection des individus au
préalable donc c'est extrêmement
intéressant c'est novateur c'est très
développé maintenant est-ce qu'on en est
à ce point de développement moi je pense
que le professeur ce talent nous le dira
sans doute il est beaucoup plus au sujet
que moi il nous parlera des vaccins et
messager dans la rage
il nous parlera des vaccins est un
messager dans l'influencé de leurs
résultats et certainement exergue
allemand des résultats des vaccins arn
messagers sur le coc u19 puisque les
études personnellement je ne les ai pas
vus et je souhaite qu'elle soit qu'elles
soient publiées largement tous que pour
qu'on puisse se faire une idée
raisonnable de ce que c'est que de ce
que c'est que ce vaccin et ouais style
moderne mais bon cela jean paul stahl
justement sur cette hiérarchie ces cinq
phases progrès si vous êtes justement en
phase ou l'infectiologue mais je pense
que c'est obligatoire c'est d'abord
obligatoire parce que l'industrie ne
pourra pas livrer la totalité de ce qui
est nécessaire en peu de temps donc il
ya obligatoirement derrière une
hiérarchisation qui est à envisager
alors après ce que j 7 le lierre
utilisation est logique
a mon avis oui à mon avis oui parce que
il
bien comprendre que un vaccin il peut
avoir deux effets et s'il a les deux
tout va bien c'est l'idéal mais deux
effet le premier d'entre eux c'est
d'éviter la maladie et le deuxième c'est
d'éviter le portage de l'agent
infectieux pour éviter la contagion
donc quand les deux sont réunis c'est
absolument parfait mais pour l'instant
on a l'information que sur le premier
volet c'est à dire qu'il est clair que
les vaccins arn qui sont actuellement
proposées les plus avancés marche c'est
à dire qu'ils évitent la maladie le
vaccin le plus avancé
il fait état dans le groupe non vaccinés
de 69 172 cas de copines et 8 seulement
dans le cas dans le bras dans la
population qui a été vaccinée donc
l'affairé fait le vaccin est vite la
maladie c'est clair maintenant
l'information qu'on n'a pas c'est ça
pour avoir cette information il faut du
temps c'est à dire est-ce que ça protège
du portage et donc de la contagion des
autres ça c'est dans un deuxième temps
donc dans un premier temps il est tout à
fait logique de dire on vaccine
prioritairement les gens là qui vont
faire une maladie la plus grave c'est
tout à fait logique et donc je suis pas
du tout étonné que la haute autorité de
santé et fait c'étaient les faits cette
recommandation ceci dit et pour pas
qu'on tombe dans des pièges de
communication le qui n'ont pas lieu
d'être
c'est une recommandation de la haute
autorité de santé s'est pas encore une
décision de la part du gouvernement et
du ministère de santé sur cette
hiérarchie donc les personnes des ehpad
en premier lieu par définition est
évidemment beaucoup plus fragile puisque
plus âgés pour ceux qui sont sceptiques
vis-à-vis de ce vaccin ce que c'est une
bonne chose thierry lardeux noise que si
on dit voilà des enfants déjà âgée
voilà on va vacciner votre maman de 90
ans est ce que forcément on va chercher
mach est sûr est que je ne suis que
comprenez moi bien je ne suis pas
sceptique
j'attends la preuve scientifique d'une
efficacité et d'une innocuité mais je ne
suis pas sceptique moi je j'aime la
science et je prends la science donc je
ne suis pas sceptique mais je dis moi je
ne suis pas dans la béatitude c'est à
dire que je ne peux pas proposer quelque
chose savaient quand je soigne des
patients au quotidien mais pas leur dire
écoutez moi ça va être bien il faut que
ce soit il faut que ça marche il faut
qu'on soit sûr or aujourd'hui je vous ai
évoqué quelques incertitudes
il y en a une autre encore il semblerait
manifestement que les vaccins n'est pas
été testé de façon intégrale chez
l'animal moderna je crois si je ne me
trompe pas modern al-hindi bien que la
phase 2 chez l'animal n'a pas été n'a
pas été faite ou en tout cas étaient
extrêmement extrêmement raccourcis donc
ça pose de grandes inquiétudes
maintenant quant au protocole le fait de
hiérarchiser je trouve ça raisonnable de
hiérarchiser eu effectivement on va on
va aller on va aller plutôt viser ceux
qui sont les plus ciblés les plus en
danger maintenant hérarchie zeno anciens
dans les ehpad ça pose un problème un
problème qui inquiète de type éthiques
tout simplement c'est le problème du
consentement c'est le problème du
consentement comment nos personnes âgées
vont ils donner leur consentement sur ce
vaccin
moi je suis désolé comme je soigne des
personnes âgées en ehpad et jean soigne
beaucoup quand il s'agit de leur propre
ville de leur dire votre vie est en
danger parce que vous êtes menacés par
telle ou telle maladie grave
il faut recueillir le consentement de
ces personnes de savoir s'ils souhaitent
bénéficier de soins et donc il y aura
effectivement cette grosse question du
consentement des personnes âgées à part
ça par ce problème du consentement et de
l'éclairage absolue des gens sur
l'innocuité à court terme à moyen et à
long terme des vaccins à quoi que pour
les personnages et le long terme va être
plutôt court je suis tout à fait
d'accord de la hiérarchisation et de la
priorisation des vaccins ça ne pose pas
de problème mais je crois que le sujet
n'est vraiment pas là en fait il n'est
vraiment pas là le jour où on disposera
d'un vaccin sûr et fiable
il ne paraît pas question de ne pas le
faire le problème c'est disposons-nous
d'un vaccin sûr et fiable
alors on va y venir justement cette
différence de deux vaccins
aujourd'hui il y en a pas mal sur le
marché des vaccins dits modernes et
classiques on le disait l'union
elle n'en a pré commander 6 regardez
voilà nous envisageons de changer nos
conditions d'utilisation pour les
voyageurs internationaux pour leur dire
que nous demanderons aux gens de se
faire vacciner avant de pouvoir monter à
bord de l'avion
alors rien à voir c'était là le
président de la compagnie qantas qui lui
veut rendre obligatoire la vaccination
pour voyager on va faire sans les
vaccins donc dit moderne comme seither
et moderne à et des vaccins classiques
comme celui préparé par sanofi pasteur
expliquez-nous la différence jean paul
stahl pour moi tout simplement mais les
vaccins et rennes c'est effectivement
une nouvelle génération de vaccins avec
une technologie qui est différent ce qui
leur a permis d'ailleurs d'avoir une
mise à disposition industriel beaucoup
plus rapide parce que
l'industrialisation de ce type de
dossier type de technique est beaucoup
plus facile du nu d'une certaine façon
alors il ya on a l'expérience de ces
vaccins et les rênes en médecine
vétérinaire mais pas en médecine humaine
actuellement ce qui ne pose pas un vrai
problème
ce qui pose un problème c'est l'adn
c'est pas la rn sur le plan biologique
donc quand on dit thérapie génique
effectivement ça fait un petit peu peur
à tout le monde mais la rn interfèrent
que très très très faiblement dans cette
histoire génétique est en tout cas il
n'y a pas deux il n'y a pas de vrais
risques identifiés de combinaison avec
le génome de l'individu qui le reçoit
donc sur le plan de la sécurité on n'a
pas trop de on n'a pas trop de problème
sur ce qu'on connaît et sur ce qu'on a
eu des expérimentations des essais qui
ont été faits avec ces vaccins il n'y a
pas de signal supplémentaire par rapport
à ce qu'on voit dans un fax un classique
qui en termes d'effets secondaires
après les autres les autres vaccins sont
des vaccins plus
classique qu'il utilise soit un vecteur
qui est une protéine qui est à bout qui
est un virus pour amener dans
l'organisme des antigènes contre
lesquelles on veut être immunisé c'est à
dire en l'occurrence le virus de l'aco
vide et donc ça c'est des choses
beaucoup plus classique par exemple le
vaccin grippe et dans dans ces
technologies
il ya un industriel qui développe un
vaccin contre la colline qui est qui est
tout à fait similaire à une technologie
de vaccin grippe donc là effectivement
on a tout l'antériorité on a toute
l'histoire du développement entier max 1
en termes de la fois d'efficacité en
termes de fabrication et et en termes de
tolérance série l'art de droit
aujourd'hui c'est finalement l'europe
qui va décider d'acheter tel ou tel
vaccin ce que le gouvernement français
est vraiment maître à bord dans cette
stratégie en ligne aura on n'a pas de on
n'a pas d'élément n'y a pas d'élément
grand public sur ce sujet on voit qu
actuellement tout est décidé au
ministère et que bon bah on nous informe
a posteriori de ce qui va être fait ou
s'il va être pas fait j'espère que la
transparence soit totale
un mot encore sur la vaccination
obligatoire on a entendu tout à l'heure
le président de de qantas à dire que lui
il aimerait bien rendre obligatoires les
vaccins pour voyager c'est vrai que va
se poser la question si notre voisin
mais mon entreprise n'est pas vacciné
que nous on les comment va-t-on gérer
voilà toutes ces problématiques dans le
voyage dans l'entreprise
est-ce que c'était finalement une bonne
idée de ne pas le rendre obligatoire ce
vaccin jean paul stahl est alors
d'enchaîner d'abord commenté sur le les
différents vaccins qui seraient
disponibles sur le marché il y en aura
plusieurs temps oui oui parce que le
temps mais il y aura plusieurs vaccins
sas et l'inéluctable aucun industriel de
fera tout seul la rendant sortent du
marché alors le deuxième point sur
l'obligation ça existe déjà il ya des
vaccins qui sont obligatoires pour se
rendre dans tel ou tel parti
du monde et c'est bien pour ça qu'ils
avaient centres de vaccination
internationaux donc la gestion de ce
genre de d'obligations pour le voyage ne
me paraît pas poser un problème
particulier professeur élisabeth bouvet
à un président de la commission
technique des vaccinations disait
aujourd'hui peut-être qu'on saura résolu
à l'obligation de vaccination si on
estime que trop peu de personnes se
feront vacciner votre réaction télé
thriller de noix écoutez c'était thonon
d'obliger des gens à se vacciner contre
un vaccin dont la mortalité est somme
toute pas si importante que ça donc ça
posera un problème de liberté publique
auquel il m'appartient pas de réponse
mais ça posera un problème de liberté
publique de savoir si jamais on peut
imposer à une population de se vacciner
contre une maladie dont la mortalité est
pas au fond aussi importante donc il y
aura à voir avec un problème de société
et la société répondre à cette question
et je n'y répondrai pas sa place merci
jean paul stalteri tardenois d'avoir été
avec nous pour évoquer donc cette
campagne de vaccination merci à vous le
dis au revoir
l'assemblée nationale s'est penché
aujourd'hui sur le budget 2021 de
sécurité sociale un projet de loi
vivement contesté sur fond de déficits
record après 6 semaines de navettes avec
le sénat le texte a été approuvé en
lecture définitive par 67 voix contre 39
les détails du texte en images
[Musique]
oh
un projet de loi contesté qui divise les
députés écouter et bien on voit le
dérapage de la sécurité sociale qui est
due aussi à la crise que nous vivons est
la question qui va se poser c'est
comment le gouvernement entend
rembourser ce déficit
on l'a vu au fur et à mesure des des
lois de finances que le gouvernement
était incapable de maîtriser la dette
publique et de faire des économies il va
falloir que le gouvernement change son
fusil d'épaulé
sinon ce sont les générations futures
qui paieront notre dette
je vous rappelle que l'année dernière il
ya eu les exonérations qui pour la
première fois n'ont pas été couvertes
par le budget de l'état
voilà donc deuxièmement je vous rappelle
aussi que et nous nous sommes opposés il
ya le il est anormal que le la dette due
qu'aux villes soient transférés sur les
comptes sociaux c'est parce que les
comptes sociaux qui sont responsables du
coc vide nous souhaitions que ça reste
une dette de l'état et non pas là encore
en termes d'exonérations une autre qui
conquit couteau de comptes sociaux c'est
ça qui explique la situation
donc les 50 milliards m'effraie pas
spécialement parce que j'estime que les
comptes sociaux sont pas sont pas
responsables de ce qui arrive c'est
l'état qui doit l'assumer et pour en
parler nous sommes avec des nuls en
économie ce membre des économistes
atterrés
bof ouardani langue merci d'être avec
nous en direct sur rt france un texte
adopté au bout de six semaines avec un
déficit historique et des moindres
rentrées d'argent un défi historique qui
nous attend également oui mais enfin il
n'y a pas non plus lieu d'être dans la
panique ou dans la surprise on savait
très bien que cette crise sanitaire
allait engendrer un déficit
supplémentaire de forcément c'est une
crise sanitaire c'est une crise qui a
fortement touché notre système de santé
en plus comme ça a été très bien dit
tout à l'heure par monsieur cochrane me
semble-t-il
on a on a transféré une partie de ce
déficit
vers qui aurait dû être pris en charge
par l'état la caisse d'assurance maladie
très franchement ça n'est pas une
surprise et puis il n'ya pas vraiment
lieu de paniquer pas pour l'instant si
on a une troisième une quatrième vague à
ce moment-là peut-être qu'il faudra se
reposer la question mais pour l'heure
les montants paraissent tout à fait
raisonnable au regard de la crise
sanitaire majeure qu'on traverse quand
vous dites il ne faut pas paniquer ça
veut dire quoi que l'état les rincer
solide avec sa dette abyssale la dette à
six a dit ça se discute
alors ne confondons pas la dette
publique et puis la dette du régime de
l'assurance maladie qui sont deux choses
différentes normalement l'assurance
maladie c'est comme isation social c'est
géré par les partenaires sociaux donc
normalement ce sont des comptes séparés
la dette publique dans le contexte
actuel est certes préoccupante mais il
faut se rappeler que la dette publique
est détenue en grande partie par la
banque centrale européenne et que rien
n'oblige la banque centrale européenne à
sortir sa dette publique de ces comptes
ça ne me coûte rien ça ne se serait sans
impact donc là aussi sur la dette
publique qui a vraiment pas lieu de
paniquer ils ont là on essaie de nous
inquiéter pour des choses qui est au
fond devrait sembler tout à fait normal
dans le contexte actuel qui est une
crise sanitaire sans précédent lors des
dernières décennies alors le déficit de
la sécu est quand même 2 49 milliards
d'euros et ce qui met contre 46 2 26
milliards annoncés au début des débats
pour vous ça ça vous semble relativement
peu finalement pour qu'on soit bien
d'accord
oui ça me semble relativement peu pour
faire face à la crise sanitaire
l'état lui aussi prendre de décision
d'exonération de cotisations sociales
ces exonérations cotisations sociales
ont des conséquences financières
donc c'est pas c'est pas une surprise je
vous rappelle quand même que le pib
français autour de 2000 milliards
c'est relativement
c'est relativement peu de choses par
rapport au pib est de toute façon il
fallait faire criser face à cette crise
sanitaire donc très franchement il n'y a
pas lieu de jeter de mémé dans les
orties très bien alors aujourd'hui il ya
d'autres réformes qui arrive
l'allongement du congé pour le père ou
le deuxième parent également la création
d'une cinquième branche de la sécurité
sociale dédiée à la prise en charge de
la perte d'autonomie est ce que c'était
le bon moment vous allez me dire oui
puisque finalement il ya assez d'argent
peut-être non je ne sais pas ce que je
vous ai dit je vous ai dit que dans le
contexte actuel
ce creusement du déficit n'est pas
surprenant et qui avait pas lieu de
paniquer il est le il est très largement
contre nature elle est liée à cette
crise sans précédent c'est très
différent
alors écoutez on a d'un côté un
gouvernement car allonger le temps de
travail donc qu'ils réduisent le temps
de travail dans deux côtés en accordant
au moins une semaine de congé parentale
obligatoire aux parents si c'est pas mal
on est très très loin de ce qui se fait
dans les pays du nord ou où on a un
congé parental qui est l'ont élevé des
enfants les faire grandir s'en occuper
quand ils sont en bas âge ça fait partie
des tâches éminemment noble dans une
société c'est important plan social donc
moi je pour une fois qu'il ya une chose
bien qui est fait par ce gouvernement
que je vais pas bouder mon plaisir et la
création rapidement d'une cinquième
branche de la sécurité sociale dédiée à
la prise en charge de la perte
d'autonomie mme une bonne idée selon
vous ça dépend
quelles seront les missions et la
définition de cette nouvelle branche de
l'assurance maladie en soi je n'étais ni
pour ni contre
tout dépend comment les choses vont être
définies et dans quel sens elle vont
être orientées
merci beaucoup d'années dans l'économie
ce membre des économistes atterrés merci
nous avons un petit peu rassuré en tout
cas à verser est vendeur vraiment pas
lieu de paniquer une fois cuche tour
doit dépendre de ce que va faire la
banque centrale européenne avait tout la
dette qu'elle engrange message est notée
merci dans quelques instants rester avec
nous nous partirons en israël ministre
de la défense benny gantz a gelé ce
dimanche sa commission d' enquête sur
l'achat de sous-marins allemands après
une demande de la justice une affaire
dans laquelle sont visés des proches du
premier ministre benyamin nétanyahou et
puis direction le liban qui entame
aujourd'hui un déconfinement partiel
après deux semaines de fermeture quasi
totale du pays
[Musique]
quand vous voyez ce qui se passe
aujourd'hui avec cette deuxième vague
avec ce deuxième au film en est ce qu'on
pouvait faire autrement plus vous
dépister - les jambes et ça a été vu en
allemagne quatre fois moins de morts
qu'en france ça a été vu en autriche 4
fois moins de morts provence a été vu en
corée du sud et c'est pas ça ne profite
pas de cette deuxième confinement pour
dépister systématiquement de les choses
vont recommencer
il y aura une troisième vague au
printemps et un troisième confinement et
ce pays sera évidemment cloués au sol
et il n'y a pas une façon plus une
pauvre de défendre un système que de
dire qu'il est moins pire qu'un autre le
peuple ça fait une volonté collectés
vous le savez comme moi que des gants
dit il n'y a pas d'alternative on sort
du public
il est clair que tout le monde attend ça
est-ce que c'est grave
est ce que c'est normal si on veut
sauver la vie sur terre il est probable
qu'il faille prendre un certain nombre
de mesures un peu autoritaire c'est
intéressant on comprend que vous soyez
déçu l'univers une forme c'est quand
même des hommes comment ces mecs-là
arrive à dormir la nuit là aussi je
pense qu'on a vécu quelque chose d'inouï
et gilet jaune c'était des valeurs de
droite
c'était des gens qui travaillent c'est
des gens qui avaient envie de
transmettre quelque chose à leurs
enfants
[Musique]
le droit on doit éviter les dérives
idéologiques merci de le souligner
comment peut-on reconstituer une sixième
république qui ne soit pas la doublette
parlementaire ça se passe en direct
puisque on est en direct
il y a quand même la liberté je vous
remercie de m'avoir invité
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
la chasse est un lobby donc il pèse très
lourd il faut arrêter de dire que on a
besoin des chasseurs qu'on a besoin de
régulation on n'a jamais eu la preuve de
ça cette réduction du débat justement
entre le tout blanc a le tout noir ne
nuit-elle pas finalement à l'idée même
que les français pourrait se faire de la
chasse je crois pas que ce soit réduire
le débat de rappeler que c'est un
plaisir qui va jusqu'à la mort cc c'est
ça l'essentiel et c'est pour ça que
c'est un sujet très très épidermique
parce que c'est une histoire de vie et
de mort il faut protéger la végétation
faut protéger la faune il faut protéger
notre santé
tout ça c'est y est n'oublions pas tous
nos problèmes viennent du mépris qu'on a
sur le reste du monde vivant donc il
faut il faut arrêter de laisser les
chasseurs faire leur bêtise et je suis
poli
on vit tous les jours sans faire
attention que tout en dépend c'est
l'unité de mesure de toute chose une
convention admise par tous s'il arrive
quelque chose tout s'arrête
[Applaudissements]
vous conviendrez que c'est l'argent qui
fait tourner le monde
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
peu importe que ce soit des bitcoins ou
du bon vieux cash
nous vous parlerons de tout sans langue
de bois
[Musique]
21h30 heure française soit il est
bienvenu en direct sur rt france si vous
nous rejoignez en israël le ministre de
la défense benny gantz se reporte sa
commission d' enquête sur l'achat de
sous-marins allemands
une affaire à laquelle sont liées des
proches de benjamin netanyahu
c'est le procureur général qui a demandé
le report de cette commission
gouvernementale afin de ne pas
interférer avec l' enquête judiciaire
cette commission gouvernementale a été
annoncé il y a une semaine par benny
gantz ce qui a irrité le premier
ministre israélien et qui a dénoncé une
provocation électoraliste miami
netanyahu qui n'est pas directement visé
dans cette affaire est en revanche
inculpé depuis novembre pour corruption
fraude et abus de confiance
et pour en parler nous sommes en direct
depuis tel aviv avec paula slayer
journalistes pour rt internationale
c'est notre rubrique vu de l'extérieur
bonsoir paula slayer merci d'être avec
nous en direct sur arte france
quelles conséquences aurait pu avoir une
commission d' enquête sur la sphère des
sous marins sur le gouvernement d'union
je souhaite un passionné que ce problème
en dure depuis deux voire trois ans la
police à enquêter sur le rôle du premier
ministre israélien benyamin nétanyahou
temps à cette affaire des sous-marins et
ont découvert qu'il n'était pas
personnellement impliqué le ministre de
la défense benny ganz a décidé de mettre
en place une commission denquête qui
fonctionnera d'après lui sous les
auspices du ministère de la défense et
on est en droit de se demander pourquoi
sachant qu'il ya six mois il a rejoint
un gouvernement de coalition avec l
netanyahu à l'époque qui le benny ganz
avait dit qu'il n'est pas besoin en tête
apparemment il a changé d'avis pourquoi
et beaucoup de personnes disent qu'il
pourrait s'agir d'avancer ses pions sur
l'échiquier politique qui a l'effet car
il a un désavantage dans les sondages
politiques
lui-même dit qu'il a été forcé de
prendre cette décision après la
rencontre de plusieurs du membre du
gouvernement israélien
quant à l'effet sur le gouvernement il
est certain qu'il sera négatif cela va
renforcer les tensions et pourrait
mettre en danger voire même détruire ce
gouvernement de coalition
alors cette affaire des sous marins on
s'y intéresse un peu tout de même des
questions subsistent quant à la décision
d'acheter les navires à la firme
allemande au lieu de lancer un appel
d'offres à d'autres sociétés c'est bien
de cela qu'il s'agit
tout à fait c'est le coeur du sujet il y
à des questions sur la raison de cet
achat à hauteur de milliards de dollars
cet achat de bâtiments aux prêts et une
entreprise allemande de 100 marchés
publics sont effectivement appel
d'offres à d'autres entreprises on pense
qu'il pourrait s'agir d'une affaire de
fraude à hauteur de milliards de dollars
benyamin nétanyahou n'est pas mis en
cause personnellement mais plusieurs de
ses proches dont des membres de sa
famille ont été impliqués l'ancien
ministre de la défense a dit que
benyamin nétanyahou devrait être soumis
à une enquête l'armée pose également des
questions concernant ces bâtiments
était-il vraiment nécessaire de les
acheter
aujourd'hui clairement à qui profite le
plus ce report de commissions
oui nous avons un gouvernement de
coalition en place en israël et ce
gouvernement est en difficulté depuis le
tout début
et la raison pour quels bénéfices l'a
rejoint
c'était le coronavirus un problème qui
devait être gérée mais on lui a
également promis que dans deux ans dans
18 mois il allait lui-même devenir
premier ministre
donc à l'origine il était à son avantage
de ne pas parler de cette affaire des
sous marins mais le public israélien et
les ministres israéliens étudie la
question depuis un certain temps donc
qui en bénéficiera le plus
et bien si benyamin nétanyahou est
coupable alors que jusqu'à présent on
disait qu'il était innocent si on se
rend compte qu'il était impliqué alors
l'avantagent sera pour benny ganz cela
l'aidera dans les sondages cela
renforcera sa position au niveau
politique mais quelles sont les
conséquences pour le gouvernement
le gouvernement est déjà très instable
en israël donc s'il enquête continue et
s'il enquête a un impact négatif sur
benyamin netanyahou alors le
gouvernement d'unité pourrait
s'effondrer et nous avons déjà eu trois
élections en à peine un an et ses trois
élections n'ont pas permis de former un
gouvernement viable donc ce n'est pas
une très bonne nouvelle pour le public
et les politiques israéliennes donc la
commission a reporté ce qu'on peut
s'attendre clairement à ce que cette
affaire ressurgissent
les jeux call louis hamelin avait
effectivement la sphère pourrait
ressurgir pour le moment le procureur
général freeman doit prendre une
décision il doit décider de ce qui va
arriver à vera et même de beat a demandé
à benny ganz de reporter cette enquête
ce disant qu'il veut réexaminer la
procédure pénale si il décide qu'on peut
relancer une enquête
alors il y aura une réouverture de
l'enquêté
mais s'il dit l'affairé close alors il
n'y aura plus dans la quête
donc c'est bien avira et mal de le blick
le procureur général qui aura le fin mot
de l'affairé en attendant qu'ils te
savoir ce qu'ils décident concernant
cette enquête est le suspense reste
entier donc merci pour la sla hier
journalistes pour arte internationale
d'avoir été avec nous à voir donc parler
de cette affaire et cette commission
reporter merci à vous en iran les
circonstances de la mort du scientifique
iranien assassiné vendredi restent
encore floues l'iran accuse israël
d'être responsable aucun commentaire
pour le moment de la part de miami
netanyahu mais des signes pourrait
laisser penser que cette attaque était
prémédité par les services secrets
israéliens
david khalifa
un hommage digne des plus grands martyrs
de la république islamique mohsen
fakhrizadeh mort suite à une attaque à
la voiture piégée vendredi a eu droit à
des funérailles nationales
un public limité composée
essentiellement de militaires les
ennemis doivent le savoir ceci est leur
première défaite
si leur objectif était de tuer notre
cher martyrs pour faire oublier son nom
désormais son nom est louée par tous et
il est devenu une idole pour tous ceux
qui s'engagent sur la voie du combat
la cérémonie teintée d'émotion a laissé
place à un sentiment de revanche sur
leur ennemi juré israël comme un symbole
le cercueil du scientifique a été déposé
dans un important sanctuaire chiite dans
le nord de téhéran où reposent deux
autres scientifiques assassiné en 2010
et en 2011
l'iran a pointé du doigt israël dans ces
meurtres précédent comme dans celui ci
la nation iranienne est trop intelligent
pour tomber dans le piège de la
conspiration mise en place par les
sionistes
il pense à créer le chaos mais ils
devraient savoir que nous les avons
démasqués et qu'ils ne réussiront pas à
atteindre leurs objectifs maléfique des
accusations restées pour l'instant sans
réponse
benyamin nétanyahou sur les réseaux
sociaux est resté évasif
pourtant sur ces images tournées en 2018
le premier ministre israélien mentionne
le nom de ce scientifique tués lors
d'une conférence de presse sur les
dangers du nucléaire iranien et ce n'est
pas tout la responsabilité de l'état
hébreu prend de l'ampleur avec ses
déclarations d'un responsable israélien
au new york times ce samedi il affirme
que le monde devrait remercier l'état
hébreu une formule reprise par l'ancien
ministre israélien de la défense
have no idea encore une fois je n'ai
aucune idée de ce qu'il a fait ce que je
peux dire c'est pourquoi cela s'est
produit et pourquoi il est important et
essentiel d'arrêter cet effort continu
massif de militarisation nucléaire si on
se réveille un matin dans un monde où
téhéran possède deux trois ou cinq armes
nucléaires ce nouveau monde sera
terrible ce sera un cauchemar pour tout
le monde
pour les états unis pour la russie pour
tous c'est quelque chose que le monde
doit arrêter les autorités iraniennes
accusent également les moudjahidine du
peuple un groupe d'opposition en exil
d'être derrière ce complot
en tout cas cet attentat vient remettre
de l'huile sur le feu dans les relations
entre les etats-unis et l'iran joe biden
souhaite changer de cap
faire revivre l'accord de vienne par le
dialogue pour à un gel des recherches
nucléaires
sauf qu'en attendant la passation de
pouvoir donald trump et benyamin
netanyahou souhaite pousser leurs
adversaires dans ses limites
l'iran entre deux eaux doit choisir
entre des exigences de vengeance et une
volonté opportuniste de sortir de son
isolement
mais le liban en tabac son tour un
déconfinement partiel après deux
semaines de fermeture quasi totale liée
au corps d'un virus le liban avait
atteint le nombre de 125000 qu'un de
kobe 19 recensés depuis février dès ce
matin les écoles rouvrent donc leurs
portes avec alternance de cours en ligne
et en présentiel et restaurants ouvrent
à 50% de leurs capacités alors que les
bars et boîtes de nuit reste fermé les
mariages sont toujours interdits et le
début du couvre-feu est repoussé à 23
heures au lieu de 17 heures mais le
gouvernement reste prudent c'est ce que
souligne ahmad hassan l'ex-ministre de
la santé écouter
le taux d'occupation des lits en soins
intensifs dédié aux coronavirus varier
entre 80 et 90% aujourd'hui nous avons
atteint les 65 à 70%
le danger est toujours présent les
résultats du confinement apparaîtront la
semaine prochaine et on espère qu'ils
seront moins graves
et pour en parler nous sommes avec navy
abi rached médecin cardiologue un
bonsoir et merci d'être avec nous en
direct sur rt france le liban qui passe
donc la barre des 100000 contamination
et va donc se dé confiné partiellement
est-ce que c'est prématuré ouais écouter
la situation est vraiment complexe aux
différents cas d'une part nous avons le
couperet de la maladie et l'autre peint
le dos de nos taux de positivité dans
notre pays atteint les 15% et malgré les
deux semaines de confinement que nous
avons le déconfinement encore donné des
résultats concrets
nous sommes aujourd'hui encore à 15% de
deux posit de taux de positivité le taux
le le taux élevés n'a pas encore atteint
ses objectifs
novaes confinement n'a pas atteint ses
objectifs
mais non un déconfinement basse et les
prudents était décidée par le
gouvernement car il ya de l'autre côté
la pression économique la situation
grave dans les politico économique
varanges pas les choses alors allez
julien pardonnez moi je vais vous faire
un petit peu recommencer parce que la
liaison était pas bonne et on vous a
perdu quelques secondes sur ma première
question je vous demander si c'était
prématuré de descons filet partiellement
j'imagine que peut-être vous faisiez
allusion à voile à ces impératifs de
santé évidemment sanitaires mais aussi
peut-être à la situation économique du
liban c'est bien ça
exactement le liban est partagé d'un
côté de 7 à cette urgence sanitaire
cette catastrophe est cette cascade de
complications avec l'évolution du coc
vide et dans l'autre côté la situation
économique très précaire car le liban
vit depuis quelques mois une situation
économique que des plus mauvaises de son
histoire
donc il faut faire un juste milieu
c'est pour cela que le gouvernement a
tenté un déconfinement partiel et
prudent cela étant les deux semaines de
confinement vont pas porter le résultat
les résultats du mois attendue car le
taux de positivité
quoique stable reste très élevé à 15 %
c'est pour cela qu'on se pose des
questions sur la prématurité de ceux des
confinement
pour quelles raisons docteur ces mesures
ont été un échec au liban comment vous
vous l'expliquer d'un côté les deux
semaines je pense ne sont pas suffisants
pour porter à 1 fry leurs fruits
concrets
d'un autre côté de confinement n'a pas
été respecté dans toutes les régions du
liban de façon homogène et a dirigé et
d'un autre côté donc les régions audi
bande le confinement était un peu
hétérogène
c'est à dire peut-être de mauvaises
décisions de la part des autorités il
aurait fallu peut-être faire autrement
selon vous le dire que les autorités
libanaises ont fait un grand pas dans
l'amélioration du dans le renforcement
du système sanitaire autant que possible
car les moyens sont limités
les deux semaines ont permis aux
hôpitaux et au secteur médical de
souffler un peu
le secteur médical était saturé encore
nous avons près de 80 85 et 90 % des
lits de soins intensifs qui sont encore
occupés 70 % des 10 de l'hospitalisation
régulation encore occupés on savait que
les coller que les patients du coc vide
ne sont pas
ne peuvent pas être guéri rapidement il
faut un séjour hospitalier assez
prolongée les moyens du pays sont
limitées les moyens financiers du
ministère de la santé des autres
ministères sont limitées car la crise
économique sévit depuis des mois et
depuis presqu'un nombre nous contacter
nous allons du au liban d'une
catastrophe à l'autre depuis l'arrivée
puis la rue de l'exécutif puis
maintenant l'absence de gouvernement
sans panier sans oublier de parler de
l'événement majeur du 4-août l'explosion
du 4 août qui était un désastre pour
tout le secteur notamment de ses clubs
de santé qui a perdu pendant des mois
près de 50% de sa capacité notamment à
beyrouth
donc les moyens de lutter contre la
maladie sont concrètement difficile d'un
autre côté le corps médical lui même est
touché gravement mars est passé très
vite et assez par cette épidémie nombre
de nombre de nos collègues sont
malheureusement décédés d'autres sont
confinés autant les infirmières que les
médecins sont touchés par cette par
cette épidémie graf
aujourd'hui évidemment les lueurs
d'espoir vont vers le vaccin partout
dans le monde notamment en europe on en
parle beaucoup est ce que c'est le cas
au liban
sur ce plan quelle est la stratégie
adoptée par le gouvernement
évidemment nous attendons comme tous les
pays du monde les vaccins leur
efficacité leur disponibilité j'espère
que ce serait pas ça va pas tarder
longtemps pour l'instant nous voulons
insister et hélas nous devons insister
sur la nécessité de respecter les
consignes médicales autant par tous les
citoyens que par les professionnels car
le meilleur moyen mais non que nous
avons c'est la prévention la prévention
les mesures sanitaires la distanciation
le port des masques d'aération sondés
sont des impératifs c'est à most
actuellement car c'est notre seul moyen
de prévenir la maladie
une fois il faut attendre que vite après
on sait pas l'évolution c'est vrai qu'il
ya des critères de notre évolution mais
l'évolution peut être imprévisible
merci nagy abi rached médecin
cardiologue au liban d'avoir été avec
nous pour nous exposer cette situation
également compliqué
au liban du côté de la crise sanitaire
merci à vous dans le reste de
l'actualité l'armée azerbaïdjanaise
récupère son dernier districts contrôlés
par le haut karabagh conformément au
cessez le feu du 10 novembre dernier les
habitants arménien du corridor de
latchine qui est relié le haut karabagh
à l'arménie entreprennent donc un voyage
périlleux vers erevan sous la
surveillance étroite de soldats russes
moscou accentue également sa présence
médicale avec une aide des plus vite al
walid ben bella ni un départ à
contrecoeur ses habitants du district de
latchine obligé de plier bagages à faire
tasser vaut dans une voiture route
enneigée
le chemin vers l'arménie sera rude
nous avons laissé tout ce que nous
avions à la maison nous ne prenons que
le bétail
nous avons laissé toutes nos affaires à
la maison nous vivions là mais comme ce
sera donnée aux azerbaïdjanais et bien
nous quittons le village nous emmenons
le bétail à goris en arménie et oui
c'est notre vie
un accord de paix à respecter sous
l'égide de la russie après le district
de khan babar celui d'acs dames c'est au
tour de la chine de passer ce mardi sous
pavillon azéri mais le chef de ce
dernier district souhaite se montrer
patriotes jusqu'au bout ce sera 15
michel aulas le drapeau de l'artac
flotte sur le bâtiment de
l'administration
je serai là tant que le drapeau flottera
pour l'instant je ne peux pas dire ce
qui va se passer dans quelques heures
nous avons eu une information officielle
selon laquelle bernard agave noé sus
trois localités du district reste
arménien ce qui signifie que la vie de
la population arménienne serait possible
là-bas dans le sud le corridor de
latchine des plus stratégiques
une bande de terre de 5 km qui relie
l'arménie le haut karabagh la présence
militaire et donc renforcer les soldats
russes du maintien de la paix
multiplient les contrôles routiers à
proximité notamment des postes de
l'armée azerbaïdjanaise
tout est calme et tranquille ici nous
suivons toutes les règles de l'accord
nous n'avons aucun problème avec les
soldats de la paix russes et en même
temps les citoyens arméniens utilisent
la route librement nous ne créons aucun
problème
[Musique]
au total dans ce conflit les
séparatistes du haut karabagh ont
rétrocédé sept districts à l'azerbaïdjan
près de 2000 soldats russes ont été
déployés depuis le cessez le feu
dimanche deux premières unités médicales
militaires sont arrivés à stepanakert 60
médecin militaire russe et un hôpital de
campagne pouvant accueillir jusqu'à 40
personnes ont été installés au coeur de
la capitale du haut karabagh pour aider
les habitants restant à panser leurs
plaies
erevan a les familles des soldats
demande de l'aide
ils étaient environ 500 personnes à
s'être rassemblés dimanche devant
l'ambassade de france dans la capitale
arménienne le but réclamer de l'aide
donc afin de retrouver leurs soldats
disparus durant le conflit au karabagh
écouter certains nous sommes ici pour
essayer de faire entendre notre voix au
sein de la communauté internationale
afin de pouvoir en quelque sorte
récupérer nos soldats capturés
nos braves enfants
je suis la soeur d'éric magail ans qui
était le commandant des forces spéciales
pendant l'occupation
dumont omar en 1991 et qui a disparu
je suis venu aujourd'hui pour les
prisonniers qui sont en captivité
je ne veux pas qu'ils subissent le même
sort que mon frère c'est la fin de cette
émission merci de l'avoir suivi on se
retrouve dans quelques instants pour un
point complet sur l'actualité de la
jambe
[Musique]
comment choisissez-vous un film un
projet à scénario